this is a production of cornell
university
i am going to introduce
the next speaker
uh and david duda i feel like i can
personally attest to the quality of his
um winemaking because he was kind enough
to give me some
wine a couple of years ago when i was at
in western new york and it was delicious
but david duda is a winemaker and
blueberry grower who runs duda's blues
in machias new york his signature wine
is made from blueberries but he also
creates blends from rhubarb raspberries
and other fruit
22 will mark the 10th year anniversary
of duda's blues and dave is joining us
today to share how and why he went into
wine making and i'll offer advice for
anyone here considering making the leap
into a value-added product
and david i know you don't have a
presentation but um if you are sharing
it you should be if you're on the
presenter view your picture should pop
right in there and i'll let you take it
take it from here
all right i'm here can you hear me
perfectly all right
thank you laura i'm glad you enjoyed the
wine i gave you a couple years ago
um
let me start out uh
by kind of giving you
an idea what i eat where i came from
what i do here uh
i was born in buffalo buffalo native
i've lived in new york state all my life
um
i bought my farm about
uh 30 years ago
and i
on the farm there was 400 blueberry
bushes so
we started
oh picking blueberries and selling them
uh
and kind of wind up wound up where we
are today
uh
before
i go too much into the farming part of
it i just want to tell you i i'm a
retired truck driver i drove truck for
33 years and i was very very lucky and
fortunate i have three million miles of
safe driving was never involved in any
accidents or anything so
i guess i was pretty lucky there
um
i guess how we could start out here is
uh we bought the farm about 30 years ago
like they said um
and we started
actually started had people come over
and pick our blueberries
it was while i was still working full
time
so i really didn't when i first started
didn't really know much about marketing
or anything
so after
maybe five or six years after owning the
farm we started taking our blueberries
uh
up to the markets in buffalo new york
and uh
well i guess i'm getting ahead of myself
for a little bit i want to tell you a
little bit what convinced me that was
the question to get into this uh
blueberry farming
it was about
oh i would have to say
maybe 12 13 years ago i was
uh making wine giving it away i i didn't
sell it or anything at that point and
i had some wine i took over to my
youngest son joe's house one day
and his girlfriend shelby was there and
uh
we opened a bottle of wine and was
drinking it and uh shelby says mr duda
your wine is so good you should make
this stuff and sell it and i thought she
was just being you know nice and
uh just commenting me uh but
uh it happened a couple of times i went
over and she kept trying to convince me
mr duty you should make this wine and
sell it it's so good and then other
people were telling me the same thing so
i was kind of wondering yeah maybe there
is some truth to this maybe i am making
some pretty good wine
uh so
the
the
i guess the final straw was i went to
joe's house one day and
uh
again shelby says you know you should
make this wine and then my son jose is
dead
shelby and i are going to get married uh
in the near future here and we were
wondering if you could make the wine for
our wedding so we could do our
traditional toast instead of using
champagne and i said yeah sure i'd love
to do that for you guys
uh so
um my first question to joe
was joe do you have to get married and
he says no dad we we're gonna plan this
uh i said well when were you when are
you planning on getting married he said
about a year and a half from now
and i said that's great i said that's
about how much time i need to make this
wine i didn't you know i didn't want to
rush it or anything so
anyway so the wedding day uh we're at
the wedding reception and
uh the grooms traditionally get up and
thank their new father-in-law's and
their fathers for you know the wedding
and all the procedures that it takes to
make a wedding and he says and i want to
thank my my
dad for making the blueberry wine
and uh this is
it's still i get emotional today
thinking about it
uh
so
when he said that
he thanked me everybody in at the
reception stood up and applauded me and
i that i never had anything like that
happen in my life and i think that that
was the thing that changed my uh whole
attitude about going from hobby into
full-time
at that point i had a couple more years
of driving to finish up about three more
years or so and then
when i retired we started making the
wine i applied for my license and it
took a little time we got that and
that's the story how i got interested in
it uh
so we started making the wine after i
got the license and we were taking our
wines to the farmer markets
and uh
we sold it there for a few years uh and
then we were in a market up in alden new
york and it's just a summer event so we
were there for for the whole summer and
at the end of the summer
um
we weren't selling there anymore and it
just happened there was a liquor store
uh in that plaza
and about two or three weeks after the
market my phone rang and it was the
owner of the liquor store and he says
i'd like to speak to the owner of judo's
blues and i saw you speaking to him
he says
he goes i keep getting people keep
coming in here every day asking for your
wine they said they want to know why
you're not at the farmer's market and if
if he could sell it
so he called me a couple of times and we
decided to give him some wine and he's
been a regular uh customer he's been one
of our retailers that we distribute to
now uh which are very few at the moment
uh but our plans are to expand this year
and we're gonna probably go
uh be selling the more retailers this
year
uh but
so as
my business has been expanding here uh
four years ago uh we we could see the
growth really starting to take off so
uh we uh
cleared some lands some virgin ground
here and when i cleared the land it was
all wooded property uh we checked the ph
and it was 4.8 which is perfect for
blueberries i didn't have to amend the
soil or anything it was great so
we put in another 4 000 bushes and uh
we probably will start harvesting from
them this year and next year should be
really good harvest from them
uh so
that's where we're at now we're uh
expanding our marketing and uh we have
to take this business to the next level
business has been so great
uh for the last three years every year
our business has doubled for three years
in a row
and i can see where we're really really
going to benefit from uh all the hard
work that we've been doing here
um
so
um
already going here
so yeah we're working on expanding our
marketing and another thing uh we
decided to do uh this year was uh
uh not only am i a vendor now but uh now
i'm a
rookie distiller i guess uh i have
friends that know about distilling and i
played around with it a little bit and i
just bought a 100 gallon copper still
that we're gonna put in production here
probably in a couple of weeks
uh we planned on doing it sooner but uh
just before the holidays about a month
before the holidays
the wine business just it was almost out
of control i had no time at all to set
my still up and start distilling so the
wine business is phenomenal so what
we're doing now uh we're getting into
the distilling part of it and we take
our our wines that we make and we're
going to run through our still
it's a copper still and uh which is
great for uh for brandies in fact it's
ideal that's what you want on a copper
still and really brings the flavors up
nice and everything so
that's where we're headed um
and
things are really starting to shape up
around here they're looking really good
we're getting really busy
i got a great family
that backs me up my wife is wonderful
she helps me with shipping we do ship
all across the united states we started
about two years ago
and that business is starting to pick up
we're building a website to work on so
we can get
a little more sales online uh especially
today with everything going on with
in the public with the cover and stuff
like that we think that the website
might be a good direction for us to head
into right now
um so
dave can i ask you a couple questions
and maybe read some from the chat box
absolutely please do anya um i am
wondering how of all of your production
how much goes to fresh fruit sales and
how much goes towards the wine
production
okay um
well that's a good question uh
let's see about
probably five years ago i would say 50
50 and right now
we don't
sell anything at markets right now
because i just don't have anything more
available the business has been growing
so much
that we couldn't sell anymore
at the farmer markets we just take our
wines uh
to the markets now okay uh but now with
the
the new plantings this year if things
pick up
uh possibly we'll have some but i think
basically we're really looking at not
selling a lot of blueberries for the
next few years probably we need
everything we can get for production
okay
and do you harvest everything by hand
uh yes right now we do uh
i'm lucky to have a few amish families
around here and uh i have about 12 amish
girls that picked for me
uh and uh yeah that we do everything we
pick everything by hand right now um we
are planning on expanding a little bit
more we want to put in
oh we're looking at probably over the
next few years i'd like to plant another
25 or 30 acres uh blueberries so at that
point uh we'll probably uh purchase a
machine for machine picking because uh
that's quite a bit
quite a bit to harvest by hand
so we have we have a few minutes here um
and so people can either put their
questions right into the chat box or
they could even unmute themselves and
ask their question
it might be easiest for us to you know
unless we get a flurry of questions
um
jessica is wondering which varieties
work well for you
well uh when i when i bought my farm
there was already five varieties here
uh my favorite from
all the blueberries that are on my farm
i would say
are my uh herbert's
you don't find
very many of them for sale but if you
can find herbert's they're a wonderful
berry
especially for making wines and brandies
and stuff they're
not the very best uh berry to take to
marketing because they don't hold up
very well but the flavor is phenomenal
and you know when i pick and take them
to the winery to uh
to process this it might
they don't really uh
you know it's not like um
what am i trying to say here uh
they the shelf life isn't that great on
them but if you're using them like i am
for what i use them for
they're phenomenal for flavors and stuff
uh then we have another variety called
covell it's an older variety
very reliable high yields delicious
flavors so i would have to give those
two berries pretty high marks on my farm
great um iran is wondering if you have
any issues with birds
uh yes i do we fur
we feed the birds every year here they
probably uh get about 10 of my crops i
don't have uh bird netting up and stuff
like that but
uh we're looking into one of those uh
they called bird cannons or something
it would probably help us a little bit
uh but yeah you know they're not
detrimental but yeah it is it certainly
is an issue and if
if you're thinking about putting in a
big patch you should consider maybe
trying to protect them from the birds
because
once they find them they'll be there
every day until they're gone
yeah that's for sure and our
guesstimation for bird losses of almost
30 percent for most places that don't
have any kind of bird
control strategy
jim
is just wondering if you are
anticipating that the wine business will
keep growing and
that's really what you're planting for
is the wine business not so much for the
fresh fruit market
uh yes uh the answer to that would be
yes we're not really gonna
we're not gearing toward marketing
blueberries right now because the
business is growing so fast
uh and now that we're gonna be
distilling we're gonna need a lot more
berries so
uh we're planning on using every bit of
our stuff for uh value-added products
for our farm
okay that's great
um matthew's wondering what your biggest
challenge has been on your with your
farm business
hmm
biggest challenge um
i would say uh
you know the labor part of it you know
it seems like it's uh
every time i need to get the work done
i never i can never make it on schedule
i'm always trying to find people who
help me uh get things
uh you know caught up so you know i
would say the labor part of it is the
biggest issue and
with that said i'm looking into the
future uh when we do want to expand more
and i'm absolutely looking into a
machine to help me pick because that's
probably one of the biggest issues that
farmers are faced with today especially
here in uh
up in the northeast and and there's
farmers in new york we uh
we have a little issue trying to find
people come and work on the farms in the
summer so
and that's it's the hottest part of the
season i can understand
why maybe it's a little bit harder to
get to work on days like that but uh
that's
one thing that we're faced with is labor
issues
i would have to say that that's probably
the most uh
difficult thing we have to deal with
here
all right
um
uh chuck is wondering if s battling
drosophila affects your product
oh
yes
somewhat uh
not so much as uh if i was gonna go to
market uh because
uh when we pick our berries
um we don't spray anything we don't
spray we haven't even sprayed organic
sprays and uh i think this this is gonna
be the fourth year if we don't spray
anything at all this year
uh
what i find is that if you're out there
and you pick every day
and you're not taking them to market
that's one advantage i have uh is i can
take them and put them right in the
freezer get them cooled down in a cooler
and put them right in the freezer
so that really
does save a lot of headaches for me
uh and i talk to people
all the time about
uh some of my berries if they have a
little blemish on them and i point that
out they don't really care they're more
interested in not having uh
anything any sprays or anything that
seems to be the most important thing
that consumers
and wine consumers do because i you know
i talk to people at the markets they
want to know how i process my wines and
how i do it and do i spray or not and
they're really happy to hear that i
don't spray they they really kind of
like that about about my products
all right that's great there's some
comments from gary about hydrogen
sulfate i think that's for maybe the
session before this i'm not sure but he
also
yeah
and he also says to try an air dancer
for bird control which has been shown to
be pretty effective
um
to try to discourage birds
so that might be yeah
um
i have a question about the shelf life
of fruit wines i have been told by some
people that fruit wines should be drunk
within the year that they are
made is that true
uh
i don't know
i i can tell you my wines uh i've had
blueberry wine
that's been five years old in a bottle
and it's good
now i can tell you i've had blueberry
wine that's been seven years in a bottle
and it's not that good
uh my sister called me up one day about
four or five years ago and she says hey
i found this bottle of blueberry wine
you made uh like five years ago and i go
oh we'll have to drink that sometime
well another year or two went by and it
was about seven years old i went over
and and i have to tell you it was not as
good as it was when it went in the
bottle so
uh i don't i would have to disagree with
one year especially with my wines i know
my wines uh we do we don't use any
sulfites or anything in our wines and
they still are fantastic after five
years
uh but i always tell people when i sell
them a bottle of wine i'll get a
question once in a while
well how long can i keep this bottle you
know how long will it be good and i tell
them
look at take that bottle home and drink
it as soon as you can and come back and
get a fresh one you know
and they always come back so maybe
there's something to that you know
that's great
do we have any other comments or
questions for dave um
anybody else want to
offer their insight on these kind of
value added products
if you don't have any questions i would
like to make a comment on value-added
products for farmers uh
if there's anybody out there that's a
farmer or thinking about being a farmer
and you want to grow crops to sell them
to the big guys
take 10 of them crops and make something
out of them you know make jam or jelly
or something
it's all extra income for your farm and
believe me you you need all the extra
income you can get
uh
i i don't really
i wouldn't recommend just being a farmer
to grow blueberries and salt you know do
something with them you know i if i just
grew blueberries to sell them i don't
think i would
you know i think i'd be struggling a
little bit my wine business has really
been fantastic
for me and and
uh you know i'm just so grateful for
that
it definitely uh definitely look into
making something out of make juice make
soft drinks for children or anything
we're actually looking into stuff like
that for our future
so if you're if you're a berry farmer
you know i urge you to look into you
know
making stuff out of your products
because uh you'll make a lot more money
you you will and that's what you you
really need all the money you can
get your hands on to survive in this
business so please look into value-added
products and uh
don't sell 100 of your stuff to somebody
that's going to make something out of it
you know cut that guy out a little you
don't have to cut them right out
altogether but
save a little bit for yourself
that's great advice um i have a couple
more questions here and
because we still have time we'll go
ahead and try to get them answered
what sort of press do you use
uh i actually uh
i don't press my stuff i i actually
grind it up i used to use a meat grinder
and now i've got a thing they call a
buffalo chopper
it's not a motorcycle it's it's a little
machine that grinds up your berries and
it like
emulsifies them it just whips them right
up into this like puree and i just put
that into my barrels and uh
man that stuff settles out so beautiful
that's that's what i do i you know
everything goes right into the primary
fermenter
that's great we've got a question from
kevin do you test the berries brix
levels before you harvest
uh i do yeah uh and you know usually uh
they're a little bit lower than i want i
like to start out at about 21 bricks so
sometimes i uh i'll wind up adding
a little sugar so i can get my bricks up
so
we want to be up there so we have a good
alcohol content so
uh yeah it definitely is very uh
a very good idea to check your bricks
and you know aim for 21 or even higher
when you're making fruit wines
all right great um there's a question
about how you price your wine
how i price it yes okay uh well we
figure everything into it you know labor
costs and uh
uh all the time that we've got into it
and um
we uh
we don't really compete with the guys
that sell or wine cheap my wine
it's not cheap but i'll tell you one
thing we put a lot of love into it and a
lot of work goes into it so i think it's
worth every penny that i charge for it
and i never have anybody ever complain
about my prices i will admit i'm a
couple dollars more than the guy next to
me but we do have i'm going to tell you
we probably have the better choice
that's good
and
lastly i've got a question about how do
you control weeds in a planting of your
size
uh
well it takes practice but i do have a
one of those uh
weed whackers and i go i don't get too
close to the plants uh so i do use uh
the weed whackers to knock down the
weeds in between and i usually have like
two guys going at the same time one on
each side of the road
and i watch them very carefully because
you do not want to get too close to the
plants obviously you don't want to hurt
them
uh but we do put uh we do put mulch on
there we have uh
uh
we used to use sawdust but uh we're
hearing that that's not the best thing
anymore
it will change your ph and your soil too
uh which is beneficial if
you know if you're using it to take it
where you need it uh but wood chips seem
to work best it seems like not too many
things like growing in big wood chips so
i would recommend that to anybody that's
planning on
putting in a blueberry patch
all right great
um david thank you so much i wish we had
been able to order tiny little bottles
for everyone who attended so they could
all have a little virtual taste testing
but
next time next time we'll think of that
thank you very much for joining us could
i have just one more minute sure okay uh
if anybody's interested uh you can order
my wines uh on dudeosblues.com
and uh you we do ship anywhere
uh make sure they like our page on
facebook oh yeah if you if you could
just uh
like our page on facebook that would
help us out tremendously we can always
give me a message for ordering also yeah
you can also yeah just send me a message
uh if you want to order and i'd be glad
to talk to you and take your order and
then just one more plug before you go i
would like to uh
um
ask everybody if you haven't already
joined the new york state berry growers
association please consider joining us
because it's a great organization and
i got to tell you they've been
tremendously helpful for me
anything i didn't know about blueberries
or
raspberries or any kind of berry they're
there to help you and they have all the
experts in fact the experts are with you
here today all the people from cornell
university work with us and uh it's a
great benefit you have all the
benefits of cornell when if you join new
york state berry growers association
because they all we all work really
close together
and
then also i'd like to thank uh everybody
and my family for helping me to get
where i am today
that's about it thank you for the extra
time
um
god bless all the farmers in america and
god bless america
thanks david very much it's really
really enjoyable
thank you so much
all right our next speaker is chris park
um chris is an extension associate and
researcher at the dyson school of
applied economics and management at
cornell
her work focuses on the economics of
fresh produce and she's contributed
much to our understanding of the fruit
and vegetable market in new york state
today she's going to be talking to us
about the latest survey of berry pricing
in new york state and chris you should
be able to share your screen
so um first of all i really do want to
thank the new york state berry growers
association for funding this project
it's um it's a project that was um
started by marvin pritz a number of
years ago
and then um miguel gomez uh in our group
in the dyson school has
has
taken it on
this study uh last
in 2020 was actually
conducted by one of our graduate
students but uh she has left
and uh is in graduate school uh in china
and um so i'll be presenting her results
okay
so
you know i think it's really important
to revisit the question you know why are
we conducting this uh very pricing
study and
what happens is we we conducted every
couple of years so actually you'll be
getting another survey from us
um at the end of this growing season in
the fall of 2022
but it's it's important because um for
one thing dairy farms need need
information and they need data and
pricing information and pricing data
at least for new york state berry
grovers is not collected and
disseminated by
any of the government agencies
so this study is very important and uh
the other the other idea is that um you
are using so many market channels and
sales channels
and the the prices
um
for these many different channels are
are never collected individually by any
of the state or federal
price reporting agencies so this is
another area where this studies is
particularly
useful and important
so um
this is the berry pricing survey that we
released uh in the fall of 2020
um
it was a very difficult year for for
everybody um at that time
so um
we want to thank everybody who did
participate
um in 2020 we thank you very much for
participating
we sent the we it also what's very
interesting we sent the um the survey
out in two forms we sent it out as a
paper uh mail-in
survey and we also sent um
links to an online
uh survey
and actually um most of our respondents
preferred the paper mail-in survey which
i have to admit
it is very a lot easier i think for our
respondents to complete and and send
back
but the online survey uh was available
about 75 percent of uh respondents
filled out the mail-in survey and about
25
completed the
survey online
so uh
as i mentioned 2020 was a it was a
difficult year for everybody um
our numbers were down a little bit since
uh
2018.
you notice that in 2018 our total
respondents was 117 and in 2020 we're 99
we hope that those numbers will come up
in the future as as
perhaps things get a little easier for
people
i have to say that if we look at the
distribution of responses that we
receive in 2018
uh to 2020
really the proportion of respondents who
are conventional versus organic and by
other measures is very very similar
um
so we actually feel very comfortable
with with um
how our respondents represent at least
what we got back in 2018
so 48 of our respondents uh
grew and sold only one type of berry
however 52 of our respondents um sold
two or more types of berries
as far as acreage
again as i said we were very very happy
to see that the percent of respondents
that we received in
various sizes the distribution that we
saw from 2018 and 2020 was very very
similar so as we compare prices between
2020 and 2018
um we feel much more comfortable knowing
that this distribution was very similar
between the two study years
now how did the respondents use various
marketing channels
the big number that i saw
that drew my attention
was that
so many more of our respondents are
using many more
marketing channels in 2020 than they
were in
uh an earlier study year of 2009
so
80.3 percent of our respondents
um
sold through u-pick channels
and
[Music]
40.6 percent sold wholesale
and 76.8 percent sold retail so
um
if you look at 2009
which is early on in the berry pricing
studies
um
probably not very many respondents were
utilizing all of these marketing
channels so when we will look at the
year 2020
so many of our respondents are are using
you know almost as many marketing
channels as they can manage and i so
that brings me to another point is that
the more marketing channels that you use
and you sell your berries through really
the the more
management time you have to put into
um
uh understanding how to price for each
one of those channels so i want to
applaud
all of these um all of these growers who
are using and managing so many different
marketing channels
i do want to point out that the
the channel that i call retail here
actually uh encompasses
what i had to do was collapse several
different retail outlets and collapse
pricing data from farmers markets farm
stores
retail retail stands and online orders
into one
what i call the retail marketing channel
and this is because um
data were
if you looked at all of these different
individual
farmers markets
farm stores
online orders
um the data was a little too thin so i
collapsed those into one
uh
one
channel that i i called retail
so what were the berry prices like so
this is a table um
of different types of blueberries
for the three major um
marketing channels
the year 2018
the year 2020 and then the column on the
far right which is the change or the
difference between the two years
and i
you know
very happily i i
i'm happy to report that that the change
in 2020 you know was was good
um most of the marketing channels you
and as presented here you pick and
wholesale in particular uh were higher
in 2020.
oddly enough you know as you can see
here the retail
channel
in 2020 was actually priced lower than
in 2018
and
um
it was fairly consistent by every
very variety
so
one guess would be that um maybe
consumers were shunning
going inside farm stores so maybe
berry growers reduce the price a little
bit on retail
that's just a guess and perhaps um
maybe in the chat if you could
mention um your your own ideas on why
we tended to see the retail price drop
from 2020
from 2018.
the other prices looked good there were
gains in prices in you pick and
wholesale
but fairly consistently the retail
prices
seem to decline in
2020.
these are for blueberries and
strawberries
here is the table for raspberries and
blackberries
so
again you can see good prices in 2020
some declines in retail for fall
raspberries
um the prices on blackberries we didn't
have quite as many farms selling
blackberries
so i'm not quite as comfortable
um
uh
in interpreting some of the changes that
we see there because the berry numbers
might have been a little scarce
for those prices to be fully
representative of what was happening in
the state
but
again if you have any ideas of your own
and want to place them in the chat i'm
sure that
we'd all
appreciate your your insights into these
one thing that i also wanted to mention
other than the
good prices in 2020 compared to 2018
the wide ranges in prices that uh
growers reported were reporting
so this is a table that has the average
price per pound
on the left and it also contains what
the minimum price was for that very type
for that market channel and the maximum
price and you can see
just for blueberries you pick operations
but a large range
uh is being charged across the state
um
now
what uh
what we want to consider
is that um you know these these very
operations can be quite varied for
instance that maximum
might possibly include
organic producers whereas the minimum
perhaps might be
those growers who are producing
conventionally so
depending on a farm's cost
will help determine the price that they
are selling for
we can see that this
this is uh trend repeats itself over
very tight and repeats across every
marketing channel
so a wide range in prices being charged
across the state
[Music]
so as i mentioned before
some of the price differences might be
according to what production method is
being used on the farm there's uh
organic versus conventional
some
growers also might be
growing
with season extension
protected environment um
they might be
producing
um in greenhouses during the off season
and able to
um get a better price at during
different times of the season so we have
to consider that
berry varieties you know berry varieties
the dane neutral or the specialty
novel berries um
and varieties could command a price
premium
and you know possibly some of the farm
services that are available if it's just
particularly accessible or
um the labor assistance that's involved
that the farm has to hire and
also
last but not least is the farm location
is the farm
in a welsh new neighborhood is it in a
very urban setting where it's close to
um
consumers that are that are able or
interested in
uh particularly interested in local
berries
this will also help provide the ability
of a farm to command a higher price
if you're in a rural area you're and
you don't have the luxury of having
consumers around who can pay a high
price premium then you have to adjust
your pricing expectations
so for 2022 our upcoming season just
some ideas that um
for you
to consider when you're when you're uh
starting to price your your berries this
year
um
make and or follow your pricing strategy
um what kind of pricing strategy do you
want and do you want for every market
channel that you're selling in
and know your cost so know
what your costs are going in to your
sales
so that you know
and and also understand what margin you
need on top of your production costs in
order to pay for your selling and
marketing costs and
don't forget to include
um profits for yourself
um and also evaluate the prices in your
area um what are retails
retailers selling berries at
what are other farms selling berries you
might even want to go online and please
the online facebooks
um to see what other farms are
are going to be charging or are are
charging
and
also consider this takes a little more
management a little more time management
but you might also want to implement
some tier pricing if you think that's
appropriate for your farm
for instance if you want to target
certain customers in your u-pick if you
want to target
those customers who
who are picking for volume
maybe you set aside a special day or
have a have an early bird price
there are opportunities i think to
to your price if you want to
um
and
lastly and not leastly and i'll repeat
this you know know what your costs are
going in
um and and don't don't um
don't undercut
your prices
without knowing what your your true
costs are and and include profitability
uh with that
so i just want to say again thank you to
the new york state berry growers
association i do want to say again that
the next very pricing survey is actually
going to be coming this fall so
please consider
um filling out the survey when you get
it
look forward to the survey coming out
because the more respondents that we
have the better that the information we
will have going to
uh
going back to you
um in addition um
[Music]
we will be um conducting
um
interviews and surveys about um
[Music]
the minimum price increases for labor
and um
for
for the um
employer employee overtime rates which
hopefully will not be changing this year
but we will not know until the board
makes a recommendation and the governor
passes
that recommendation
if it's passed but we will be conducting
those interviews in that survey
this winter soon and if you get a call
from us
please consider
being a part of that
very important research
so if you're interested in a copy of the
2020 report it can be found at this url
i'm sorry it's very long
um
but if you would like a copy you can
also just email me
ksp3
cornell.edu and i can send you a copy of
the report
okay that's all i have
and i would be happy to answer any
questions
thank you very much chris that's really
interesting and it's um
i have to admit for me it's kind of
confusing sometimes trying to figure out
why
why some of those things are the way
they are
um
there are a couple quick questions um i
don't know if you saw these
um wondering about the possibility of
asking growers to report prices by
container size
half pint court
or make something
and there laurie made it
you know comment about converting maybe
having a quick conversion
thing in the description about
uh a pint two and a quarter what that is
for poundage so if you want pounds
to be reflected maybe you could help
them somehow convert it or something
like that i don't know i think that's a
really good point no that is a really
good point we we do offer a conversion
on the paper survey it's very hard on
the online survey to handle all of those
options but at least on the paper survey
we have and actually on the online we do
have a conversion so one and a half
pounds per quart 0.75 pounds per pint
some people were more comfortable
writing down their per quart
price in the paper survey
um
but they need to indicate if it's per
quart or if it's per pound so
we'll try to do a little better job of
clarifying that we do have the
conversion
we do allow people to respond
by court or pint on the paper survey
it's very very hard to
have that ability on the online survey
so we'll we'll think about that hard and
and that also brought up another um
point that i forgot to mention
is that um
[Music]
when you are
when you're
pricing your product
um
consumers also need to understand how
your
how your product is priced compared to
maybe retail because they see retail all
the time at retail if they're buying
strawberries in a clam shell the clam
shell might be
10 ounces it might be 12 ounces it might
be 16 ounces
so that price varies at retail you know
according to
the size of the clam shell
um but you do have the unit price there
at retail
what some consumers tend to forget is
that when they go to say a farm stand
um and they see
the price of a quart
and they see that quart priced
higher
than the
um
then the 16 ounce clam shell at retail
they don't reap
they don't realize that your farm price
can be very very competitive on a per
pound basis
so if you're selling per quart or per
pint and you want to highlight how
competitive
it is with say local retail
local retailer prices then you might
want to
have special signage that says the per
pound price
so that's also just something to
consider
um
when you are marketing your berries
either at the farmer's market or your
own farm stand
that's great kristen thank you so much
there might be a few other uh questions
in that chat box that we didn't get to
and i would love it if you wouldn't mind
taking a peek through them and trying to
answer if you wouldn't mind
and i do want to just say one quick
thing that for those of you who are
wondering about quick conversion guides
in the berry guidelines the cornell pest
management guidelines for berry crops
which we put out every year there is a
beautiful conversion chart for all
different kinds of things on in chapter
two and it converts quarts of fruit into
pounds of fruit and quartz into pints
and pines into quartz and
and then it does a whole bunch of other
conversions for pesticides so that might
be helpful for you folks if you don't if
you have a copy of that look look in
chapter two
all right i'm gonna move on i don't want
to get us too late and thank you so much
kristen for that it was really helpful
um our next speaker is dr heather uh
grab is a senior lecturer i hope i'm
pronouncing that right heather i
apologize is a senior lecturer and
researcher at the cornell university
school of integrated plant sciences for
years she's been studying the well-being
of pollinators across diverse
agricultural systems and today she'll be
talking about how to manage weeds as
well as pollinators in a strawberry
field
so heather thank you so much for joining
us and
i'll let you go ahead
thanks laura and anya for inviting me
today i just want to confirm can you
guys hear me okay and see my slides
beautiful
lovely okay thanks um so the
the topic i'm gonna talk about today is
um drawn from data that we've been
collecting from there's many familiar
names um in the meeting today whose
farms we've surveyed
over the last several years looking a
lot at plant diversity crop diversity
and um in my case my passion which is
insects so i have a couple different
examples in the images here of some of
the farms that we worked at and
in terms of
management styles you can see the
diversity of different
systems that we were working in but all
within
june bearing strawberries so matted row
systems in june berry is still what
we're seeing is the most common
production style but one trend that i've
noticed is even within june bearing
strawberry production i'm seeing a lot
more
of the plastic mulch for weed
suppression and to help keep plants and
fruits off the soil so seeing that used
not just within the rows but also seeing
a lot of the weed suppression fabric
between rows and even some growers that
have been experimenting with using
living mulches between the rows so
there's an example here and the left of
a grower that was using
a living mulch that was then terminated
just before flowering began in the
spring so i'm going to start off with
talking a little bit about the
distribution of weed pressure that we
saw across the farms that we surveyed so
in this plot every farm has two points
that are connected with a line and what
we saw is that grasses were generally
the most problematic weeds on farms in
some cases making up more than 40
percent of the cover within these
randomized meter squared quadrats where
we did
our sampling but we were also seeing in
many cases
some problematic forbs as well showing
up in plantings
many growers did a great job of keeping
their weed pressure
quite low and of course a lot of the
farms that were using
these
intensive weed suppression systems using
black plastic and using weed fabrics did
a good job at keeping weeds low although
only around 20
of the farms that we surveyed were using
this plastic mulch and we did certainly
see examples of growers who were using
matted rose systems that were still able
to keep weed pressure quite low
in this case through pretty intensive
hand weeding practices with uh big crews
that were going out and suppressing
weeds or through
pretty regular use of herbicides or
pre-emergent herbicides
we also noticed although we tried to
standardize the age of fields that we
were sampling within that some of those
um fields that had been in production
for several years of course were more
weedy than those that had been more
recently established
as part of our broader surveying efforts
on farms
looking at weed pressure was just one
small component we also looked at
fruit production and part of that survey
work was using these sentinel potted
plants that we put out on farms so
unsurprisingly farms that had really
high weed pressure had lower overall
production
but by using these sentinel potted
plants we remove that competition factor
that weeds have and we also in some
cases were able to minimize some of the
issues of microclimate that's created
when there's heavy weed pressure in a
field so that we could see what some of
the effects of those in-field weeds are
mediated through other routes of action
so in that case
by
influencing pest pressure dynamics
within the crop
or by influencing natural enemies or
even beneficial insects like pollinators
that may all also influence yield in the
crop
and curiously what we found is actually
that some of our farms that had the
highest weed pressure
had lower
damage in their fruit and higher average
fruit weight so higher quality berries
produced at these sites that had higher
levels of weed pressure again that's
just in the sentinel plants where we've
removed the competition effects so
clearly there would be
strong effects on food production in the
field themselves
but when we look at some of the
most common needs that we found so again
grasses which are really hard to
distinguish among species we saw of
course
crab grasses and also some nutsedges
that were problematic in some areas but
many of the other weeds that are forbs
were some plants that provide floral
resources potentially for
beneficial insects so things like purple
dead nettle or
yellow rocket fleabane especially in
field margins was a common one
and we know that there are many insects
that are very important for strawberry
production systems that can be found in
close association with many of these
different weedy species so
one example here that you're seeing
across almost every
weedy plant species is that brown plant
bug the tarnished plant bug here
but also some beneficials are associated
with many of these as well so many
different
native wild pollinator species that
could be promoting
yield and pollination on farms
some previous work that we did across
farms in the region in
2012
found that tarnished plant bugs are
causing as much as 40 percent damage to
berries across the farms that we
surveyed but fortunately there is a
complex of natural enemies
in a genus of wasps that include some
species that are both native as well as
some that were introduced by the usda
that do provide fairly good control
of tarnished plant bug populations
particularly when there are floral
resources around and natural habitats
that can support
the that natural enemy population
when we're looking at fruits
um many people
are
able to distinguish between when
a malformation on a fruit or a cat
facing
is likely to have been caused by the
feeding damage of plant bugs versus by
poor pollination damage but i will say
these frequently can look very similar i
have seen
and tried to score for damage hundreds
of thousands of strawberry fruits and
i in this case know confidently because
these were experimentally exposed to
either poor pollination or to an
herbivore but there's also very many
cases especially in particular cultivars
or when tarnished plant bug feeding
happens early that it's very challenging
to distinguish so the overall sort of
guidelines are that when you have
large well-developed seeds that are all
clustered together that's a very likely
to be symptomatic of tarnish plant bug
feeding
whereas a similar kind of damage but
having very small seeds is more likely
to be poor pollination damage but it's
really hard to distinguish so if you see
these kinds of damage
on your fruit it's good to think about
what the insects are that you were
seeing in the field
during flowering and just after
flowering
we also know that pollination is pretty
important for strawberry not equally
important across all cultivars but this
is data that we took from
joule which at the time of our survey
was the most common cultivar grown
across farms and likely is still quite
common within the region we did a couple
pollination treatments on all of the
fruit across the farms that we surveyed
doing bagging so that flowers were only
able to self-pollinate by wind or
by their own pollen
some open pollination where flowers were
exposed just to the pollinators that
were available at that farm and then
supplemental hand pollination so we can
see what the maximum size of fruit would
be if pollen was not limited at the site
and we do see about a 45
increase in yields comparing the self to
hand pollination but we also see that
the open pollination is not as high as
hand pollination is which indicates to
us that while
the insects that are on a farm are
providing some good pollination services
it's not always enough to meet the needs
of the
plantings across farms and so if we
break this down so this is every farm
that we surveyed where their data is an
individual bar
and we're just simply subtracting the
weight of the fruits that were produced
by the supplemental hand pollination to
the weight of produce of fruits that was
produced just through the action of
pollinators on their farm we see that
between 30 and 40 percent of farms have
this pollen limitation where there is a
pollination need that's not being met
and that's generally explained by the
number of insects that we saw
particularly wild bees that were
on the flowers during the bloom period
so if we look at the hand pollinated
fruits it doesn't really matter how many
bees we saw on a farm in our
standardized timed visitation surveys
but what we saw for
the open pollinated is that if farms had
a lot of
bees that were visiting their flowers we
didn't see much difference at all
between the open pollinated and our hand
pollinated treatment but we saw the
biggest difference at farms that had
very few visitors during our timed
transect surveys during the early bloom
period
the community of bees that's visiting
strawberry in new york is not only
incredibly beautiful but also really
diverse and interestingly
not nominated by the european honeybee
so on average across all of our sites we
have only about seven percent of visits
coming from european honeybees i think
this is
a characteristic of the diversity that
we have across all of our farming
systems within the region but i've also
heard data from colleagues across the
northeast that they see a similar
pattern in other fruit crops as well
so one question i get a lot is among all
this diversity of bees who seems to be
doing the best job
and uh there was a recent study that i
think is really intriguing from our
neighbors to the north in canada
that showed that on a per visit basis
wild bees are more effective than honey
bees are and it actually takes about
three visits by a honey bee in order for
them to start to become equal in the
pollination services that they are
providing
from wild bees
and when we have a mixed community as
would sort of naturally occur when
you're not excluding visits from one
type or another one really intriguing
result that they found is that even when
there were multiple different bee
species visiting a strawberry flower it
mattered who visited first and in an
interesting way where flowers that were
visited first by a honeybee
still had lower yields independent of
the number of total visits compared to
flowers that were visited first by a
wild bee it's not clear
why exactly that is but kind of an
interesting pattern that overall
suggests that wild bees are a really
important part of the pollination
services that are provided to strawberry
and unfortunately one of the trends that
we have seen is
that sites that have more agricultural
cover in the area surrounding a farm
tend to have the fewest number of wild
bee visits on the farm so what can
growers do if they find themselves in
this spectrum of
more simplified landscape compared to
those that have a higher cover of
natural habitats like wood lots or old
fields surrounding their farm uh one
option we looked at more recently was
using these um managed bumblebee quads
so we know honeybees maybe aren't the
most effective how about this other
managed pollinator like bumblebees that
you can bring and supplement onto the
farm we did a large survey in both um
2018 and 2019 looking at the
effectiveness of bumblebees
and we found that
um although we still do see evidence
that there's pollen limitation we do not
see
any difference in the magnitude of
change between our open pollination and
our hand pollination treatment at sites
that did not get a bumblebee
quad versus ones that did get bumblebee
quads applied to them so
the bumblebees were not very effective
at meeting that pollination need that
would have normally been filled by wild
bees
and probably a big reason for that is
that we really didn't see very many
bumblebees visiting the strawberry when
we looked at the pollen that those
bumblebee colonies brought back into
their hive we actually found on average
only about four percent of the pollen
that they were returning with was
rosaceas pollen so that's the group that
includes strawberry
and about 95 of it was other pollens
that were predominantly
weeds so they were doing a good job of
visiting weeds but not so much at
visiting the strawberry plantings
themselves so if managed bees are not a
great solution
um we've also explored other options
that growers can use like planting some
nice floral habitats on their farm
and those can provide nesting resources
of course pollen and nectar
refuge from pesticide applications or in
the case of natural enemies that might
be attacking pests it gives them some
alternative resources to use at periods
when pest populations might be low
within the crop
so we established
two
plots on 12 different farms across the
region one of the plots was just a
control planting and another one you can
see a little bit from the satellite
image this dark green patch here that's
a native perennial wildflower planting
that we put in right next to our
experimental strawberry plantings that's
what one of those plantings looks like
when it's sort of in its full glory
and what we found when we looked at bee
visitation comparing within each farm
the difference in bees or in some cases
we also looked at pests and yield
comparing this plot that had a
wildflower planting to the one that did
not
is this interesting hump-shaped curve so
here above the line means that the
wildflower planting had more bees and
actually below the dotted line means
that it had less bees so we see this
kind of goldilocks a zone with moderate
amounts of natural habitat in the
surrounding landscape predicting farms
that will do the best in terms of
increasing pollination services when
they add a wildflower strip so some
benefit but only at this sort of sweet
spot of farms and very likely that's
because in farms with very little
natural habitat there's just not a
sufficient pollinator population and to
recruit to that relatively small
wildflower planting
and at farms where there's a lot of
natural habitat adding a small
wildflower planting is a drop in the
bucket they already had sufficient
pollination services
to begin with we saw um that even at
those farms where there was a positive
effect it took about three years for us
to start to see that effect so
definitely a long-term investment and
something to think about in terms of how
you're rotating
your plantings if you're establishing
one of these
wildflower habitats that's going to take
three years before you start to see an
effect
in terms of pests we actually do see
evidence that there can be a spillover
of pests so there was sort of a
goldilocks zone again here in the middle
but no area where there was truly a
substantial benefit of adding a
wildflower planting in terms of a
reduction in pest pressure
and in some of these areas here we
actually saw
substantial increases in pest pressure
at those sites some of that
has to do with the fact that our key
pests like the tarnish plant bug
really like
many of the plants that showed up so
many of the plants here with asterisks
are ones that we planted but some of
them for example like a ridgeron that
daisy fleabane
that we saw earlier those
uh volunteered within our wildflower
plantings and they supported a lot of
tarnished plant bug but not a whole lot
of bees were using those compared to
some of the other species that we
intentionally planted into our plantings
it also was a little variable depending
on what our herbivore taxa was so
tarnished plant bugs which were the main
thing causing um damage in terms of
insects to our crop we did see a little
bit of an increase in tarnish plant bugs
at sites that had a wildflower strip
compared to controls
but
other pests like strawberry sap beetle
and other herbivores like aphids or
spittle bugs tended to be a little bit
lower and that's work that um one of the
undergraduates who worked with us
through the summer scholars program
ellie mccabe who's pictured here
spearheaded that project
so overall takeaways um from today are
that we are seeing um substantial
variation in weed pressure across farms
using some of those physical barriers
like plastic mulches or weed fabrics can
be effective although
there are certainly costs and things to
think about in terms of how you manage
those across their life cycle
grasses tend to be one of the most
impactful
weeds within the system but there are
other flowering plants that may be
providing some beneficial services in
terms of supporting pollinators or
natural enemies
overall in terms of pollination those
wild bees are really important for
providing pollination services on farms
and honeybees
and even
managed bumblebee colonies which are
quite expensive to purchase are probably
not going to be very effective
pollinators and if anything they're just
out there pollinating your flowering
weed populations
and in terms of pest management
wildflower plantings can if uh not very
carefully managed result in spillover of
pests so it's really important to make
sure that the seed mixes that you're
getting or even the volunteer plants
like fleabane are not
coming up and providing these really
nice alternative hosts for
potential pests within the system
so i'm incredibly grateful to all of the
growers some of which are pictured here
many of whom i think are on the call
today who allowed me over
many years to come and collect some of
this data on your farms i also have to
thank all of the labs that i've
collaborated with over the years and
have contributed to the project of
our funders as well and if there's time
i think we're near the end but i'm happy
to take any questions
laura we can't hear you
uh no i'm not sure what's gone wrong
hi i'll um
laura
i'm not sure what's going on but i can
take over uh we do have some time for
questions session 4 is going to start at
3 45 pm
uh so thank you so much heather for this
talk this was super interesting
um
and
jim is asking
how might you convince growers to stop
using bumblebee quads for pollination
because money
oh go ahead yeah um so i would say of
course if you see on your own farm if
you're
purchasing these and they are working
for you
that's great
one piece of data that i think was
really really impactful for me which i
didn't share earlier
is this one so we worked in
not just strawberry for the study but we
also surveyed in raspberry and tomato
and we saw very few bumble bees so there
was no bumble bees in our control plots
very few bumblebees visiting strawberry
across all the farms we surveyed that
had these quads
um and importantly in later flowering
crops especially for tomato we actually
saw that there were fewer bumblebees at
states where we had put a quad compared
to sites that don't and the main reason
for that just some work spearheaded by
another student i worked with olivia
miller is that these quads are killing
large numbers of wild bumblebee queens
that enter through these um hive
entrances when they do not have
queen excluders on them
i have a little video of that you can
see there's
queens that are wild that's a wild queen
trying to get into one of these quads if
you do not have an excluder so there's
an excluder on there that keeps her from
getting in you can easily kill 20 or 30
wild bumblebee queens and that's a
colony then that no longer establishes
and produces workers that pollinate all
of your other crops for the rest of the
season so that's one piece of data that
really convinced me
why it's probably not a good idea to
invest in these even if they were
increasing your pollination in
strawberry
oh that just breaks my heart thank you
so much for sharing that video
um i also i do need to remind everyone
that if you want dec credits
you need to fill out the survey that's
in the chat one more time we will not be
offering the ec credits in the fourth
session so this is your last chance
um
and oh oh here's a good question um
chuck is asking they see a lot of
bumblebees pollinating and blueberries
what do you think about that
so blueberries could actually be a
crop system where putting quads in
may be effective i've definitely seen a
lot of bumblebees as well pollinating
blueberries
they're very effective blueberry
pollinators because bumblebees do that
buzz pollination activity so most of the
pollination needs for blueberry as long
as there's sufficient natural habitat
around can be met by the wild bee
populations there's some great work out
of university of vermont that's showing
that supplementing with bumblebees only
very rarely
gives a positive impact although more so
than it does for strawberry but i would
still be quite worried about these
long-term population impacts of putting
these quads out
particularly when they do not have a
excluder on them which is not currently
how companies you'd have to ask
especially to get those excluders
another question that i have for you is
one time i was at a talk
um and this entomologist researcher says
that
on farms that spray pesticides and
insecticides
and they have um
they have these field borders
of wildflowers they actually found the
highest concentrations of pesticides in
those
borders which of course isn't
it's a little bit counterintuitive
so i'm wondering
where
do you think would be a good place to
uh encourage natural vegetation
in a farm system
yeah i think that's a really tricky
question i also get that a lot from
folks who are doing a lot of under
canopy management so blueberry growers
and also orchard folks who want to
figure out like if i'm spraying should i
mow down all of the dandelions and
clovers that are in my field and i think
that is a good practice to do if you're
spraying anything that has high toxicity
for beneficial insects
because they can always forage elsewhere
to find some of those pollen and nectar
resources they need but if they forage
on something toxic and they die then
you know you're out of luck in terms of
your pollinators
um
not having
your planting right immediately at the
edge but with some buffer is probably a
good idea so often in our plantings they
would be a couple meters away
from our experimental planting maybe
there's a laneway that's going in
between
the field which is also really helpful
for getting cultivation or harvesting
equipment in and out of the field as
well
thank you
and i see a couple folks in the chat are
saying that um
they see wild bumblebees on their farm
which makes me happy and sea square is
confirming that wild bees are better
than bumble bees
is that correct
um so in the case of strawberry
pollination that is correct we don't see
so there are queen bumblebees that are
flying around during strawberry bloom i
occasionally see a wild queen so you can
tell they're wild because they're really
big whereas the workers in the colonies
that you buy are much smaller compared
to the wild queens that are out they
don't tend to visit strawberry it's
mostly this other suite of really
diverse and much smaller pollinators
that are visiting strawberry and
providing services
so would these be like those tiny
uh shiny green ones exactly yeah so some
of the pictures i showed earlier
um show you just the absolutely gorgeous
diversity
of different bees that we've been seeing
in our surveys so shiny metallic green
midnight blue
red with stripes they're they're very
beautiful
that's incredible
um oh great a question from brian young
um
he says that oh it's a comet we stopped
using quads five or so years ago and we
see many more wild bees carpenter bees
small bees
that's fantastic
yeah and we've actually one thing that
was wild to see in those bumblebee
colonies um the reason why wild queens
are going in there is because it's part
of their natural behavior to try to
usurp or to steal the colonies of other
wild queens that have already
established they basically get all the
benefits of having a nest without having
to do all the work of starting that nest
and we see other bees as well who are
also trying to get in so other bumblebee
species including species that we're
really worried about in terms of their
population declines over time but i've
also seen carpenter bees in those nests
i've seen tons of honeybees that are
going in there and trying to probably
steal nectar or other resources from the
nest we see all kinds of wild things
showing up in these managed bumblebee
colonies
that's fascinating
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu